good morning Hank it's Wednesday
February 24th and this is the view out
of my front window so Hank as you know
today has been a tough day I'm worried
about a friend of mine I was going to
tell a rye bald story about red-green
the miniature dachshund we grew up with
we called him red-green because a we got
him at Christmas and B he was red I'm
not really in the mood to tell that
story instead I want to talk about my
weight loss my cleanse and how much I
love nerdfighters so my childhood story
is I used to be skinny and then despite
all the happy dancing I gained weight in
fact technically Hank since that photo
was taken in 1995 I've gained 63 pounds
now Hank I'm happy to admit that I
needed to gain the first maybe 20 but
the last 43 were strictly optional now
Hank you may remember in my last video I
said by the way Hank just for future
reference I'm counting on you and the
nerdfighters to let me know when I get
fat and you failed on that front well
Hank as usual it turns out the problem
was not nerdfighteria but my under
estimating nerdfighteria because in
November of 2009 a Facebook group was
founded and that Facebook group is
called John Green is fat so it wasn't
that nerdfighters didn't tell me I was
fat I just wasn't listening
Hank John Green is fat is one of the
great Facebook groups of all time and
its members have gone to extraordinary
lengths to find every picture of me in
which I look as fat as possible Here I
am bragging about how I just ate a box
of cheez-its that's a picture from my
friendly fool code I was taken as I
walked out of a 7-eleven at 3:30 in the
morning there I am eating pizza and
there's me eating a taco wrapped in a
pizza yellow no I'm at the Pizza Hut no
I'm at the Taco Bell I'm not that
combination Pizza Hut and Taco Bell oh
and Hank then there's this picture which
is me during the five seconds I had a
mustache with the word pizza underneath
my face I don't know why I love that but
I know I want it as a shirt so Hank I
want to thank the nerdfighters for
providing all that convincing and
humiliating evidence that my puff was
descending into my body and the long and
short of it is that since Henry's been
born I've lost almost 15 pounds but Hank
I don't will you to worry about me think
I'm on some crash diet or something I'm
eating a lot every day I'm just not
eating you know french fries and I
started running well my version of
running in which sometimes I'm passed by
people who walk fast nerdfighters I'm
sorry for wrong
accusing you of failing to point out my
paw genus keep the humiliation coming in
comments it motivates me Hank I'll see
you on Friday
mmm pizza